[Music]
since we're in the middle of its
pandemic
a lot of us don't want to travel uh
especially to
big cities and whatnot so we want to
stay outdoors
so recently there has been an uptick in
camping
i knew it cross country rv trips and
stuff like that
and you've been doing a lot of that yeah
and um showing your booty on
instagram you've been showing your butt
on the ground oh
you got a cool it's fine we have a photo
shoot coming yeah we
benefit yep by the way though a lot of
chicks are actually after that booty so
it's not just you [ __ ] so
wait earlier today you just kept selling
joe to nikki now all of a sudden joe's
too good for nikki all of a sudden yeah
i think so yeah oh wow
it was the last shot that got to it no
you know what it is
joe's butt is elite and like you're like
in another
you're on his ass no no it's elite you
fell in line
your sriracha bottle and him oh [ __ ]
no now we're calling no i have to worry
about your tapatio no mine topped you
on his tamale no i'm a fan i'm a fan
now he's stepping back he's like oh [ __ ]
how did this
come up is this uh about all the rv
accidents that keep happening
no it's it's actually rv accidents
that's funny
tell me about that there's a big uptick
in rv accidents because everyone's
buying rvs and they don't know how to
drive that is that would be me so we've
been talking about doing an rv trip
and even going as far to say that we
wanted to buy
an rv without ever even driving one hold
on
i think that would be me i would i would
definitely run into something one second
rv buying is like in the here's my
powerpoint
number one let me correct one his jeans
are [ __ ]
his jeans suck out two i never said that
number three i never said that no number
four
he has a tendency to twist my words okay
i i i like to
summarize let's hear it but then in your
summary in your
in your summation what is it yes i don't
know but summation sounds summation
sounds really good you're submission
you end up twisting the entire message
okay how did it twist let's do the twist
good song thank you come on baby let's
do
that twist that's in casey's
you're right i forgot yeah true you know
what with the rvs
you're right i forgot no i mean he's not
lying we did talk about it
you better take your point you better
chalk that one up she said it
that's a big point i was trying to be
nice you guys just had to rub it in but
the point is
we did talk about this in the future
like way in the future like
oh we could totally buy an rv because
nearby there's places where we can just
keep the rv
and that's like parking spots right okay
and then so we're like cool that'd be
dope
and then also he wanted to buy a car in
texas and then do a road trip over there
and then
pick it up pick it up and then bring it
what kind of car
an suv for more camping trips and
whatnot yeah
yeah that's cute yeah yeah yeah the
pandemics
would have accepted a batmobile a marty
mcfly time machine
a delorean get it right yeah yeah yeah
okay
oh he got offended for the layman oh
okay got it got it but not not this [ __ ]
no
true not an rv to drive it also we were
talking about
renting an rv to learn how to drive the
rvs to avoid that [ __ ] which is getting
one yeah we could rent one we will rent
one first for sure
it's pretty fun but you have to have a
different driver's license for them if
they're big
like massive the bigger ones yeah
they're not like a class one
or something like that yeah you could do
classy it has to be that's it for a
commercial license okay well my grandpa
could drive as our
rv drunk and he had never had a problem
really
he got pulled over and everything and
they were like oh yeah you're totally
fine dick
because his name is dick really dick
miller yes sir oh interesting
richard miller but he's like dick miller
how are you how the [ __ ] are you he just
owns it yeah yeah that's good that is
the most stereotypical like
military grandpa isn't it dick miller
sergeant dick miller a lieutenant
colonel with a sword on his wall that
had korean blood on it
wow was he associated with the beer uh
with miller miller like miller life he
would be miller bold
if they pay me then for what name
richard richard
where the [ __ ] did they get dick from
richard and dick
yeah where does dick come from richard
honestly 1950s 1960s batman
dick grayson dick grayson his name is
richard richard grayson is not so fun to
say but
so richard grayson changed his name to
dick but richard grayson had
what you came first the dick penis or
the dick
name probably the name and then people
got annoyed with a certain dick and then
started remembering
i think they kept on accidentally naming
big dick people richard
that's right wait that that you're
saying your grandpa had a big dick
my grandfather used [ __ ] is what i'm
saying casey can you type in what came
first
the name dick or penis or the dick yeah
dick or the don't click images
please click images actually in case it
gets all these dicks
oh no okay digging around eight
first things the term dick has been a
euphemism for the penis since at least
as far back as the 19th century
oh that's pretty far back was that like
eighteen something hundred yeah
yeah dictionary of slang dates the penis
sense of the word to the mid 19th
century
wait what slang dates the penis yeah but
what about the name dick what came first
the dick dick
what came first oh yeah you're right
there we go
god damn it it's that dick right there
what i deal with
what this is who i married but he's
buzzed
that's okay right is he like the sober
yeah dude okay so if this isn't too
crude of an opener i will explain myself
my question is a simple one we know the
question
hey one someone somebody had to be first
didn't they named richard thought it was
a grand idea to go by a nickname which
was also slang for the male genitalia
penis two
penis slang was personified for someone
nicknamed dick
who perhaps resembled inappearance or
actions the male genitalia
he looked like a penis three some
coincidence which cannot be explained
adding to the uniqueness of this
nickname is that dick only shares two
letters with richard
can you imagine for example [ __ ] being
an acceptable nickname for priscilla
or tits for teresa perhaps ass for osama
is on the on the way into the language
and we don't even know it yet so no one
knows where it came from
yeah i just read a bunch of [ __ ] can
you imagine being the first dick because
you look like a dick
like you look like a dick so people call
you a dick and you were so messed up can
you imagine he was like
a child and be like you look like a
little dick
but richard was such a good like famous
name back then that everyone used wait
what is the story about
uh we're talking about camping and how
oh i love camping
let's go what what yeah so a lot of city
people
are trying penises
so a lot of city dwellers are camping
for the first time during this pandemic
because we can't travel anywhere else at
least
we don't think it's safe to travel
anywhere else so they want to try out
camping at least have a little bit of
summer fun
that's kind of what we were trying to do
but then all the camping grounds are
booked for like
forever let me tell you if these city
slickers are from the bay y'all don't
know how to drive so you don't need a
damn
suv or an rv none of that you can't even
drive your damn tesla's right
and it comes with autopilot yeah
slickers that's so good
you know what you was talking about
richard no i liked it though so there
was all these all these damn city
slickers what they tested
new york city new york city
yep all them city slickers in san
francisco remember that movie they said
it's so smooth though where i was like
are they bringing it back
it's cold why not that's what that's
what that is
you remember these slickers where he
jacked off the bull and he was like i
kept
pulling and pulling and only a little
bit of milk came out oh what
are we talking about talking about city
slickers
wait i want to know about camping what's
going on hold on we're talking about
jerking off balls
wait that that sounds more fascinating
right you guys remember the movies
it's more fascinating than the city do
you remember city slickers the movie yes
can you remember that scene where he was
like he got milk in the morning like i
was sour
yeah i don't know what was wrong with
the cow i kept funny pulling and pulling
but only a little milk came out
duh because it's calm oh i wonder if
that's always conscious
delicious milk i didn't see that stupid
all right so yeah so uh more camping and
a lot of
city a lot of camping and a lot of city
people a lot of city
city slickers all these city stickers
yes uh they're like i really
showed on that one it's like oh i said
city singers real naturally too
sure did sure did but yeah so a lot of
city people are realizing
camping is not as uh
glamorous and i know it's not yeah they
see the instagram [ __ ] they're thinking
they're going for the graham and they're
claiming
they're gonna do a nice little pose with
the campfire and all that there's all
these bugs
realizing it is living hell camping
there's bugs everywhere it's too [ __ ]
hot
it's [ __ ] summer and they didn't pack
enough [ __ ] because they didn't know how
to pack
it's exactly like you're you're saying
from your own experience from your last
camping journey
that is that is my experience your wife
hates you so much
what's it like ama ama ask me anything
go ahead
uh my wife hates me so much that when i
would decided to go on a camping trip
with my son
she decided to go to guess where for a
borah varsity that's messed up you
twisted the time of the events yeah okay
fine fine fine fine bora borg happened
first
and we booked the campaign see how much
he hates yourself
well i take my son oh my god oh my god
hey put some tapatio on it let's see
some of that there you go
give me give me anything you got it was
out here like when i took
my son i was like oh it's your son now
with lots i do have to say though you
did miss your family in barbara i know
that
yeah i missed youtube horrible person i
would be
like oh you guys are going on a camping
trip now i'm booking a trip to borah
board
i definitely told you you painted it no
i'm just doing this
no he is joking but i also know for a
fact that he had a miserable time
they were freezing yes we so we went in
november and
for the first time and i don't know how
many years late november so practically
yeah snow in l.a there's no in palmdale
i think yeah is where it was so
it was pretty miserable and we realized
it wasn't the
father-son bonding time that we had
hoped for and no one else was camping
next to us they were just kidding
we're the only ones on the campgrounds
so what's incredible is this guy
texts me he's like hey dude this is
called the [ __ ] i'm having a miserable
time
like like should i just hang out or
what's up and i was like get the [ __ ]
out of there dude that sucks
dick i was like already paid for this
like three nights and
uh it's the second night and uh should i
[ __ ] bail steve
this is great oh [ __ ] how are you asking
steve
well he was just asking for input he had
nowhere to go yeah i was like i need to
talk to someone there's no one to talk
to
isaac's like you know trying to do his
own like hiking adventures and he's in
his own world sometimes so you weren't
hiking with them no we were hiking he
was he was that's something
go away but like i don't know it's like
you spend like 20
48 hours with with a kid and you know a
kid mentality i would have been duggan
there's certain like conversations you
do with the kid and i'm like all right i
need i need a break i need a break that
might have been like the most fun he's
ever had in his life because the way
that kids think it's completely
different than how it is
i i would agree with you but the fact
that he's older he understood like
how cold it was you knew daddy gonna
bring all the damn food
he wanted to play video games he's like
i'm trying to force the situation he's
like
everybody is voting against this yeah do
i
[ __ ] it out do i lose the money yeah and
go home like a [ __ ]
or do i thug it out and but then
we're all night and have everyone hate
me including myself
yes i paid i stay
exactly yes but that's why i laughed
because then you were painting all the
stuff
about how they felt about camping about
the fact that it's miserable and it's
cold and it's hot and then
they forgot how to pack properly which
reminded me of like
your situation when you guys were trying
to cook and stuff oh yeah i forgot to
bring a spatula
so we used sticks to flip burgers
classic
classic pretty cool though mentality man
at least we had something
to put the burgers in because you could
have had an
open fire situation really like
authentic
camping though i thought that i'm gonna
rough it at least you brought like
propane gasoline and things like that
did you actually interrupt it
yeah good for you yeah you know propane
to warm ourselves up yeah we're gonna
have a campfire because california sucks
with
the fact that you can't start any fire
well apparently you can start a lot of
fires here actually
especially gender reveal fires that's
right
[Music]
mm-hmm